cuáles de las siguientes ecuaciones
diferenciables son separables y bueno te
invito a pausar el vídeo y vean cuáles
de estas opciones son separables ahora
bien la manera en la que vamos a tratar
de resolverlo es primero despejar a la
derivada y si cuando despejó la derivada
tengo que dèiem de x es igual a una
función de james que voy a llamar
hedayat por alguna otra función de x que
voy a llamar hdx entonces digo bien es
separable ya que podría volver a
escribir esto si divido de ambos lados
entre gti y así obtener algo de este
estilo 1 entre g d i x de james va a ser
igual a 7 x x de x pasamos de esta
primera ecuación a esta segunda ecuación
solo dividiendo a ambos lados entre g de
james y multiplicando ambos lados por de
x y luego aquí está claro que tienen una
ecuación diferencial separable porque
pueden integrar de ambos lados pero la
clave es despejar la derivada y ver si
podemos poner
esto en una forma donde tengamos el
producto de una función de jeff por una
función de x así que vamos a intentar
despejar a de 7x en el primer inciso y
dice x porque prima más james es igual a
3 bien veamos si resto que de ambos
lados lo único que estoy intentando
despejar a de 7x entonces voy a obtener
que x x de x recuerda que ye primas de
7x esto va a ser igual a 3 - así que
esté allí de ambos lados y veamos si
dimito de ambos lados entre x voy a
obtener que de 7x es igual am y es más
lo voy a escribir de esta forma voy a
escribir lo común
3 - james que multiplica a 1 entre x y
ahora sí entonces está claro soy capaz
de escribir la derivada como el producto
de una función de james y una función de
x así que esto en realidad es separable
y bueno podría multiplicar de ambos
lados por de xy dividir de ambos lados
por 3
y obtendrían 1 / 3 - report de james es
igual a 1 / x de x así que claramente
esta primera opción es separable bien
vamos a trabajar con la segunda y bueno
de aquí podemos restar 2 x 2 james es
más déjame hacer de vulcan primero voy a
restar 2x en ambos lados y después voy a
restar 2 james en ambos lados 2 de aquí
y 2 de acá y también voy a sumar 1 de
ambos lados entonces suma 1 aquí y
también sumó a 1 a camps y que voy a
obtener bueno me quedaría estos 2
eliminan estos 2 eliminan y estos dos
eliminan y tengo que dos veces de 7x es
igual a menos 2 x menos dos más uno y
ahora puedo dividir todo entre dos y voy
a tener que dejen de x y bueno esto se
puede simplificar me quedaría menos
x
- james más un medio ahora no es obvio
para mí cómo escribir esto como el
producto de una función de x por una
función de gem así que esta segunda
opción no parece ser una ecuación
diferencial separable no sé cómo
escribir esto como una función de x por
una función de james así que no va a ser
separable bien ahora trabajemos con la
tercera opción
tengo esta ecuación diferencial y
observa ya la escribieron como una
función de x por una función de james
así que esta opción es claramente
separable y si quieren que haga la
separación puedo volver a escribir esto
bueno primero recuerdan que primas de
allende x y entonces si multiplicó de
ambos lados por de x y divido entre
ambos lados por ye cuadrada más voy a
obtener lo siguiente voy a obtener 1 /
cuadrada más james que multiplica de
james esto igual a x cuadrada más x x de
x así que es claramente separable
ahora vamos a la última opción esta es
interesante básicamente aquí han
distribuido la derivada entonces pues
vamos a actualizarla si tuviéramos que
factorizar la derivada no solamente la
voy a factorizar me quedaría que si la
saco de aquí y de camps de x que es mi
mismo factor esto va a multiplicar a su
vez a x + jim y esto es igual a x ahora
si tuviera que dividir ambos lados
entre x ma jin voy a obtener que dejen
de x es igual a x entre x más ya que mi
equipo de herramientas algebraicas no
funciona no hay forma de separar a x de
ayer para poder escribir las como una
función de x por una función de jeff o
al menos no es obvio para mí así que
esta opción no es separable por lo tanto
la respuesta es solamente la primera y
la tercera opción
esas dos van a ser separables